modern entrepreneurship can be for
everyone all of us
are immersed in a culture that has
taught us
that non-stop work is the most valuable
thing
the brain needs breaks we're not great
if we're hitting it hard
constantly
i know she is hi believe nation we have
the one and only marie forleo in the
house
superstar entrepreneur uh writer of the
book everything is figuratible
founder of the b-school entrepreneurship
program
welcome aboard thank you so much for
having me it's so great to be connected
how you feeling
i'm feeling great i was going to ask you
that question because i saw that you
just
came through your hysterectomy yeah
which is major
surgery yeah and and how are you feeling
i am feeling so much better so it's
basically
two months ago since the surgery and uh
as you said it's a major one right it's
a really big one
and my doctors warned me they were
amazing they were like you know for six
weeks you're not gonna
really be able to do anything besides
just gently walk
and i'm a person that has so much energy
and working out is a way for me to
maintain
and strengthen my mental and emotional
health so oh my goodness
i was a mess for those six weeks that i
couldn't work out but it's been
a little bit of time i've had my
workouts every day so i'm feeling so
much better thank you so much for asking
too
so so why don't we start there because
in 2019 i did
i did a tour of the us and i broke my
neck two-thirds of the way through
and broke my neck in two spots and had a
concussion and
everybody was asking when am i coming
home and i said i'm just gonna
try to keep going because being with
entrepreneurs is part of my healing
right like serving and getting up
it's part of the healing but on some
days just getting out of bed
by myself was a victory so
so for you who's like this is a that was
you know a year and a half ago for me
for you but this is
still pretty recent and you're still not
100
what's the advice that you have for
entrepreneurs who are
ambitious and go-getting and want to do
stuff and then
and then life kind of punches you in the
face
and and suddenly you can't do even the
things that
you used to do in your sleep like how do
what's your advice
yeah well first of all i think that it's
so important that when
anything happens with your health that
you press the pause button
and you listen right so for me it was
about getting to the doctor and
honestly the way this i even learned
that i had this enormous tumor
growing inside of me is i was on a face
time with my best friend
uh her name is chris carr and she
happens to be someone who lives with
stage four cancer peacefully for like
over a decade
and so we're talking like we normally
talk and i was like oh and she's like
wait
what was that i was like oh i was
probably eating something that i
shouldn't have been eating and she's
like no
that's not gonna fly she's like we need
to get you into the doctors immediately
to get an ultrasound so
here's the answer to that question right
i was like no no no i have too many
things going on i don't want to slow
down and get this ultrasound and
because she's my best friend and she has
leverage on me in the sense that
i trust her i love her and when she
needs to get firm with me
she knows she can go there she's like
i'm going to call josh you know my
partner we've been together
almost 18 years she's like you're going
to get the ultrasound like this is not a
negotiation i was like okay fine
so that was for me the big thing it's
like when life comes at you right and i
was like okay i either have this choice
to listen to my best friend or to keep
overriding it because it's not that big
of a pain it was just a moment it only
comes and goes it's not constant
but then when i went to the city and i
did all the tasks you know blood tests
stool test
mammogram uh ultrasound and
everything was turning out good until
the ultrasound came
and literally the radiologist turned the
screen
and she was like wtf do you realize
you have a tumor larger than a
grapefruit growing outside of your
uterus
i was like no i did not know that and
she's like yeah there's like five other
ones too she's like we need to get you
to a gynecologist
immediately and obviously this is
october
so globally we're still in a pandemic on
like
so turn long story short um the doctor
was like
the way that we can get this out of you
and ensure
that it never comes back again is you
know a hysterectomy we need to just go
in and you're
not going to be able to do anything for
like six weeks and i thought to myself i
was like you know what
thanksgiving's coming up the holidays
are coming up if i'm gonna be laid out
for six weeks
this is the time i'm like can we
schedule this thing like yesterday
and funny enough it turned out my
partner josh
you know all the entertainment industry
he's an actor he's been an actor for 30
40 years uh he was shooting a movie in
ukraine
at the same time that i was getting it
was pushed like
oh my goodness like how is this all
happening at once and he got on a plane
went to the ukraine um
ukraine shooting this movie he landed he
got covered right before i'm going into
the hospital
i was like can 2020 get any
wilder so for everyone listening i would
just say that you
have to surrender a little bit to the
is-ness
of what's happening and to give yourself
permission
to know that you can take it slow for a
little bit
you're not going to be forgotten you're
not going to fall behind
there's nothing more important than
taking care of your health and your
family's health
of the people that you love and for me
it was a great gift
i mean the beautiful the the most
gorgeous thing that came out of it not
only but one of them was my parents
because josh was away
in europe and couldn't come back um i
got to spend this
enormous amount of time with them and
let them take care of me which you know
hasn't happened since i was a small
child
so there were all these blessings that
came out of it um but when it happens to
you
you know i think entrepreneurs we want
to get back up and fight right we want
to get back up and keep going
but i think that there's a lot of wisdom
in pausing when your body
needs you to and giving yourself time to
heal i love it well we're
super glad grateful happy that you're
feeling better
yeah um marie's book is called
everything is figure editable for the
youtube audience tool
there it is there it is we'll link it up
wait
is that what's the that's almost a
grapefruit on the on the cover that's
interesting orange yes but it's so a
smaller one yeah but it's a fun arch
it's a good orange so so for youtube
we'll link it up down the description
below you can go check it out
what i love about that story is it's
basically a living testament to
everything is figure editable so so
while you're going through it what did
you have any habits or routines or
rituals or just
reminders to yourself to not
try to push it harder than than you know
like what would you do
daily to try to kind of get you through
this when you're used to being ambitious
go-getter
yes let's make things happen okay this
is really important
so um you know i'm big into the habits
that i have that help me
stay sane and stay healthy so some of
those again look like working out
looks like meditation looks like
journaling
all kinds of basic but fundamental and
transformative good habits
after i went through the surgery i'm
going to be totally honest with you i
gave myself permission to do
none of that like absolutely none
the only thing i was allowed to do was
lay on the couch with my parents and
watch the crown
like that's it you know what i mean it
was like watch the crown
have a little snack take a nap watch the
crown have a little snap take him out
and i gave myself
complete permission to let go of any
ideas about shoulds oh you should be
meditating right now
oh you shouldn't have that you know
gluten-free mac and cheese i was like
nope
whatever my body wants right now my body
is going to get
and there is no beating myself up at all
so
it was actually a really nice couple of
weeks
taking a break from all of those
routines
and i actually found myself craving the
meditation again craving the journaling
again but not
until i was ready for it if that makes
sense
what was that instant or was that a day
later like how
did you decide like weeks later this was
the weeks later when you gave yourself
the permission
to to slow down and like not do the
meditation was that like
right away afterwards instantly okay
instantly i
to be really honest i had like there was
a good amount of painkillers that i was
on for that first little bit
and for me you know being on those
painkillers like the only thing that i
could do
was pay attention to the timing of when
i was going to take my meds
have enough water have enough food and
just be able to walk i know that that
sounds wild but you
when you know there's a big slice on
your abdominal wall
you have to kind of learn how to walk
again safely so i was like
not doing anything besides those you
know survival based things
right okay see for me it took me a
couple days for reality to set in
i was in the hospital and i i told the
doctor yeah so tomorrow i could just do
us
you know like everybody who would cancel
the speech on can just come over to my
airbnb
and i'll do it from bed it's like no no
you have a concussion
like you don't understand how this works
and i was hard on myself for like i need
to i need to be like
responding to email but looking at the
phone
with a concussion i can only spend like
10 minutes a day on the screen time
so how do you how do you get there so
fast because
it took me a couple days to get into it
and i think a lot of people just stay in
that
depression zone yes and it might be a
physical thing
like like a major surgery or break your
neck but it could also be a loss of a
loved one i mean when my
family dog passed away i was a wreck for
a week um
so how do people get there faster
i think that you first have to almost
step back
and realize that all of us are immersed
in a culture that has taught us that
non-stop work is the most valuable thing
we're immersed
around in media and technology that is
like
24 7 hustle and if you're not doing that
you're not living your best life or
you're not trying hard enough you're not
making enough effort
and i'll tell you personally i believe
all of that
is unsustainable i think there are
certain stages and seasons of life
there are times whether it be a month
whether it be a little stretch of a
couple years
depending on what's happening in your
career and with your family
where yeah you can put the pedal to the
metal right there's something happening
i know even when i was writing the book
and when we were launching the book
i mentally prepared i was like this is
like me going to
a version of my own olympics so i had to
build in time both
previous and then between writing it and
promoting it and then
after the book to just be like i'm gonna
be laid out for a little bit
because you know my history is i used to
be a nike elite dance athlete
and one of the ways that i would get the
highest performance for myself
and one of the things i learned
throughout that training was we would go
hard for a couple of weeks on a
completely new drop a completely new
launch of choreography
we would travel around the world we
would train hundreds if not thousands of
people
but then we would rest and recover and
we would take a few weeks if not like a
month
off so you just completely step back so
that you have that ability to rest and
recharge so you build strength and you
go back into it again
so my answer to that question is i think
that we need to do
a better job of understanding
the power of rest in recovery so that
when those things happen in life god
forbid
there's a loss in your family or you
have an illness or there's just a major
fail or a disappointment or something
comes crashing down on you
that you don't try to get back up too
fast
because there is wisdom to be gained
from taking a pause and from letting
yourself
process and look at things from a new
perspective
you know um i think that we don't do
enough of that in our culture and if
there is
a few gifts that we can take out of 2020
it was the power of the pause
right like how many people i don't know
if this happened to you but i can tell
you happened to me
just the fact that in march everything
shut down
right everything stopped life as we knew
it was just like
gone and it was this whole new thing and
in that pause i recognized for myself
how much static there was unconsciously
the constant invites you know come to
this conference that one and i'm
pretty good at saying no and honoring my
integrity around what's most important
to me and what's not
but i didn't even realize how much
psychic weight i was carrying
by how much static was in the world so i
say
all of that just to emphasize that if
you find yourself in a really difficult
position
you know if it feels right in your bones
you got to get right back up and that
feels authentic
great but if not don't beat yourself up
if you need to process your emotions you
know you can't heal it if you don't feel
it
don't beat yourself up if you want to
take a minute to be
wise and assess what has happened
how you want to learn from it and what
you might want to do differently in the
future
in my experience i don't do that in a
nanosecond i need a little bit of space
to really have some perspective so i can
come back stronger and wiser does that
make sense
yeah i love it and listen i know you're
you're the habits queen
and and also just in b-school
encouraging people to
not just build a business they love but
have that build a life that they love
right and that's that's part of the
b-school kind of philosophy over the
teaching the six weeks we're going to
help you build a business and a lot that
you love
yes i'm wondering through the pause that
you went through both with
the pandemic as well as your your
surgery
are there any habits that once you kind
of get out of this fully and you're back
to normal and even when
when the world is back to normal yeah is
there a new
habit that you've introduced that you're
going to keep or or just back to what
you were doing before
no definitely not back to what i was
doing before what i was doing before was
awesome for them right i was doing the
best i could
it was great it was all working i think
for me
one of the habits that i've introduced
during especially
covid right all of 2020 is i have so
much more of an emphasis
on joy and architecting my day
around joy so being able to
wake up and go like okay if i need to
get some writing done
old marie would have been like i'm gonna
hit it like you know what if like i'm
gonna go
for it i'm gonna have my coffee i'm
gonna do whatever
like and i'm good at that i'm practicing
that that's a very
easy place for me to go but another
place for me to go
is actually knowing the two or three
things that i need to get done in the
morning
and then choosing what feels most joyful
that day
so for example i work out every day um
meditation i'm now gently learning
italian i'm also doing a couple other
things and i'm like huh
what do i want to do first this morning
sometimes i want to take a sauna
sometimes i want to work on my italian
sometimes i want to work on my writing
but giving myself permission to be more
fluid and
let my joy lead me into what gets done
first
has been awesome and i'm hanging on to
that today even
you know today's the first day that we
opened up the doors to b-school
and there was just like one or two
errands that i needed to do
here around town years past i would have
never
let myself get up from the computer do
you know what i mean be like there's too
many things to do
and this i was like you know what i'm
good i'm gonna like drive my car i'm
gonna go do this little errand i'm gonna
come back i knew i was gonna get to hang
out with you
and so letting joy be the driver
of my days and my life i feel way more
productive
i feel more powerful and more clear than
i
ever have in my life and i think a lot
of that has to do
with loosening up a little bit is that
a conscious choice that you're trying to
build into your daily routine so that
maybe during my workout i'm planning my
day and i'm and consciously asking how
do i bring more joy
or is it trying to catch it in the
moment
of you shutting something down that
might have brought you joy because you
got work to do and just trying to catch
it like is it a conscious thing or is it
catching the moment it's almost more of
a
relaxing into it okay i could
the only way to describe it honestly
would be
that i'm very very good
at being extremely rigid and being
on task right and if anything were to
come in and try and take
me off of what i thought my day should
be you better watch out jersey marie's
gonna come and she will just take
you down this new version
is way more fluid and able to navigate
so if something comes in i'm like oh
does this really work for me you can sit
right here i'm not going to get angry
i'm not gonna get stressed this
sounds like fun and just a lot more
masterful as staying in my
zone of power without letting stress or
frustration
or anger or anything get in my way
so how do you because i struggle with
that you know if i'm
if i'm working on something and i'm in
the zone and i'm making videos and then
um my wife comes in yeah with lunch or
something it's like
oh thank you but like in my head is
and then it's hard for me to get back on
track so how do you how do you
like this is such a subconscious pattern
that yes we've been running this pattern
for decades and now you're trying to
make the ship
how do you consciously make that shift
so there's a couple things one i think
the thing that the pandemic
was really instructed for for josh and i
again he works from home as an actor i
work from home
we're all home right everybody's kind of
on top of each other because that's just
where we are right now and
josh and i have been really really
getting good at going
over our days both the night before the
week before
the morning of and letting him know like
hey from
x time to x time i'm gonna be in this
zone in the house
and that's like i need to stay focused
do you know what i mean that means the
no interruptions or whatever so
we've been really good with each other
in terms of that communication so
i'm like hey if you comment drop me here
like i'm gonna give you that kiss or
that hug or if you know you come and
want to dance for a minute like it's
going to be good but i kind of
quarantine off
those little chunks of time where it
would not be optimal it would actually
be really difficult
same thing for him if he's working on
lines or he's got whatever going on
he kind of lets me know but it's not all
day it's not
you can't come interrupt me for nine
hours i feel like
that's not nice and it's also not
realistic
really all the time especially if you
love your partner and
you definitely it's like the brain needs
breaks we're not great if we're hitting
it hard
constantly right so to build in those
little moments of love
i think it just takes another level of
communication and then for you here's
what i would recommend
recognize that you have a choice when
your wife comes in
with some food you in that moment can
either
tighten up and go like like inside
or you can go that is not a standard i'm
gonna drop anymore
anger and irritation and frustration has
no place
in this relationship i'm not going there
like if i need to have a talk with her a
little bit later and say hey tomorrow
i'm going to need this chunk is that
cool but you have to set that new
standard in yourself that's what i'm
playing with
and it works like magic yeah i think
even
even um before this we were driving
i was filming videos she was doing some
errands and on our way back
i'm getting ready for our talk and i'm
like when i'm gonna ask marie you know
how am i gonna introduce her what do i
wanna know we only got so much time
together and so i'm i'm just
zoned in and i let her know like hey hey
what are you thinking about she's
thinking about this oh i'm thinking
about
my interview with marie coming up
because because i want to ask you some
good questions
and then kind of just went back into my
zone just the communication to kind of
say where we're at has been super
helpful but yeah still the
the interruptions in the moment is
something that uh
when you're in flow you can interrupt it
just i love it anyway fantastic tips
um b-school is launching today yeah
youtube again we'll link that up in the
description below if you want to check
it out
is there anything so six weeks you know
with your video material is there
anything
new this time around or is there
anything specific for this year we're
coming through this time that you think
is going to be super valuable for people
yeah well a couple things one i you know
we were the last time we had b-school
open was basically right before covet
hit
so we had almost 10 000 people going
through the program
when the world just went and what was so
surprising to me
was uh it actually wasn't surprising it
was really heartwarming
how many b-schoolers wrote in throughout
2020 to say
thanks sweet jesus that i'm in this
program because
all of the marketing and the strategies
and the tactics
are allowing me to pivot there's one
small example a woman who owned a brick
and mortar coffee shop
and of course instantly right she had to
close her doors and she said
because of what i learned in b-school i
now have mondays my
online orders are overflowing she's
building her email list like all these
things there was a gentleman
i think in ireland who raised over 185
000 euros
to help make sure that the elderly folks
in his community
were taken care of during this crisis
and the list goes on of
all of these different entrepreneurs who
like everybody else
got shocked by what happened but they
because they had the skills and the
strategies and the tactics
were able to actually do better in 2020
than they did in like 2018 and 2019
so i think that all of us having that
framework going into this year is huge
we have a expanded team of b-school
mentor coaches who are
amazing i am so excited to work
alongside them with all of our students
um we've got new bonus trainings there's
actually new advanced trainings that
we've built in the program so there's a
lot of new components
um and it's just exciting you know we've
had over 64
000 people go through the program so
it's tested and proven yeah
and i just i never get tired of it
because you know this
from helping people transform their
lives when they come in with dreams and
ideas and things that they wanna make a
reality and you see them come out the
other side
with those things in reality it's the
most inspiring thing ever
so i know we're running out of time but
can you can you quickly just talk about
the community aspect because i think it
gets overlooked
when i meet people who've been through
b-school
they're just they're different not just
for the the learnings which are great
but also just the connection to other
people because i think
so many people are just they're the most
ambitious person
in their family and that they know but
suddenly when they join your community
then it's like oh i have all these other
people
i can talk to and learn from as well
that we're doing it together
just like i know in your life your
partner was super helpful to you your
friend
helped you you know go get the the the
test done
how important has the community aspect
been at least for me as an outsider
it seems super important but what do you
think yeah oh 100
because you're what you said is so spot
on there's so many of us that
feel for a lack of better term a little
like the black sheep in our family or
we're just out there
you know flying our little freak flag
like hey we've got these ambitions to do
this thing that is so not normal and
nobody understands what it is but i
really want to do it and quit my job
and the rest of our family and friend
circle might be like
that's not what you should do and then
all of a sudden you come into b-school
and you're surrounded by a global
community of
like-hearted people meaning folks that
believe in who they are
believe that entrepreneurship is a
vehicle to make a difference believe in
wanting to serve your customers at a
high level
and working to understand how to do this
in a way that's really aligned with your
values
and so to see so many different
perspectives and also to see people
um you know from every different country
every different belief system all
different ages we've had teenagers
through folks in their 70s
it really starts to give you a
perspective that wow
modern entrepreneurship can be for
everyone and to be able to contribute
you know if someone
leaves a comment under a video and
they're struggling with a particular
accept
aspect of whatever the assignment is and
sure we'll answer i'll answer our mentor
coaches will answer but it's also really
nice to get
support and perspective from fellow
students
and all of our grads come back for free
they can come back for free every year
so you
get the benefit of so many different
perspectives and people who are
truly loving and supportive and
non-judgmental of you of wherever you're
at
i think it's a really special place one
of the things i take a lot of pride in
is just creating a really positive
motivating environment so people you
know all of us have hard times all of us
go through different struggles
but i love the way that in b-school the
way that people treat each other
in our comment section is just it's just
awesome
it's supportive and it's uplifting and i
think you know when you're navigating
how to build something from scratch
that kind of energy makes a big
difference amazing
well that's crazy how time flies when
you're having fun
the book is called everything is figure
edible the program
is called b-school youtube will link
them both up in the description below
the one and only marie forleo thank you
for the time the love the energy
so glad you're feeling well and and
thank you for joining us today
thank you so much have a great day
everyone really appreciate you
much love bye if you want to see the
one-on-one i did with
lisa bill you check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there part of my own personal mission is
to break the idea that women
should be any right you should be an
entrepreneur you should be a mother at
the end of the day it
really is what do you want to be i'm
trying to throw stone in the ocean
and create a tsunami